hello everyone i'm rich stocks in 1997 i
heard a cassette tape by veterinarian
naturopathic physician dr joe wallick
the title was dead doctors don't lie
dr wallach's book an audio dead doctors
don't lie now has sold hundreds of
millions of copies all around the world
has become the most popular health
lecture in the world
so not only did i begin following dr
wallach's nutritional
guidelines his wellness guidelines i
began sharing his message with everyone
i knew and 25 years later
i'm still sharing dr wallick's message
i'm excited to share it with you today
the full dead doctors don't lie audio is
available free of charge on our website
mineraldoctor.com
mineraldoctor.com you can listen to the
same lecture that i listened to 25 years
ago and it's free of charge
there are several other
videos available free of charge right
there on that website and then we have
two other websites that might be of
interest to you uh for bible teaching we
have a
on our youtube channel that rich stocks
the healthy christian but the website is
rich stocks dot org
rich stocks.org
and then for those who want to reduce
maintain and control their weight
simple3slim.com on the mineraldoctor.com
website right there on the home page
there are two steps that i highly
recommend you take
right out of the gate soon as you visit
the website number one take our free
health evaluation
it does not obligate you to anything
it'll tell you a lot about yourself
about your body about your
what your body might be nutritionally
deficient in that's the purpose of that
so that you can identify
the areas of your body
that need additional nutritional support
and then schedule your free phone
consultation with one of dr wallach's
associates again it's free of charge
does not obligate you but if you are
interested in dr walleck's products
they will help you
maximize get the most for your money
and to meet the specific needs related
to you so in our last video we talked
about dr wallach's three steps to better
health let me review those real quickly
because it leads right into the lesson
today today
we're going to talk about dr wallick's
good food bad food list
good food bad food
but dr wallach's three steps to better
health were simply this number one you
identify the problem you identify the
health category
or the tissue of your body that's
breaking down we saw that almost all
health challenges fall into one of these
four categories
hard tissue problems
at your bones
joints skeletal system
soft tissue problem that's your skin
your eyes
your heart your lungs your organs
number three blood sugar problems number
four digestive problems and then we talk
to you about
the different health packs
that
you can get all
of dr wolux his 90 essential nutrients
that's his message there are 90 don't go
don't fall for the trap of what we call
fractionated nutrition
people will hear dr willock's message
and i'm amazed i say hey would you think
that oh yeah it was great
i went to the health food store and i
bought some chromium and i bought some
selenium it seems those are the two
things that jump out at people
sometimes they might have bought some
calcium well
all of these nutrients work together my
friend 90 essential nutrients
you don't go and do the fractionated
nutrition route a little bit of this
little bit of that dr wallick has put
all 90 essential nutrients together in
three
products say why is there four products
these two are the same other than some
people like a liquid some like a powder
okay but
all 90 essential nutrients right here in
these three products we call it the
healthy body start pack and then we saw
if you add this product now you have a
healthy bone and joint pack to give you
extra support
for your bones and joints then if you
have soft tissue problems we saw you can
add these two products here
and now you have a healthy brain and
heart pack to help give you additional
support for soft tissue problems then we
saw if you have blood sugar problems you
add this product right here we call it
sweetes and lo and behold you have a
healthy blood sugar pack
they give you extra support
supports and promotes healthy blood
sugar and then we have these two
products that if you have digestive
problems you add these two products you
have the healthy digestion packs so
anyway that is the simplified the quick
version of that you can watch the video
uh where we go into more detail on that
but step number one was you identify the
problem step number two i just told you
here basically is then you use the
appropriate pack and the appropriate
dose according to
body weight
this is where the phone consultation
comes in
it's going to be very helpful for you
and then step number three we said was
this
clean up your diet
what does that mean now there are a lot
of people
who
like to skip the first two steps
you start talking to them about dr
wallick and his products oh i eat
healthy well there's no such thing
you can clean up your diet we're going
to talk about it good foods and bad
foods
but just know this
we've already shown you clearly in these
other videos if the nutrients are not in
the soil
they're not in your food
it's just that simple
if you're a vegetarian they're not in
your plants
if you're a meat eater like i am if if
they're not in the grass that the cow
eats they're not in your steak
you have to supplement my friends
there's no way around it
all it means when people say eating
healthy usually they mean eating organic
and
just know this i do eat organic i like
it every chance i get
it costs more but
i can afford it now years ago i couldn't
so i eat organic but all that means is
no pesticides were sprayed on these on
the foods
doesn't add one nutrient of the 90
essential nutrients just so you know
that so step number one you identify the
problem step number two appropriate pack
appropriate dose step number three is
you clean up your diet here's how you do
it
you eat the foods that maximize
absorption and then you avoid the foods
that hinder absorption so here is dr
wallock's good food bad food list i'm
just going to read it verbatim again
this is available you don't have to try
to memorize it or take notes
this is available what i'm looking at
right now i simply printed copied and
pasted printed directly off
my website mineraldoctor.com
so here's the good food list eggs
sauce scrambled in butter soft boiled or
poached
fish
chicken
pork now some people don't eat pork
that's fine it is on dr warlock's good
food list doesn't mean you have to eat
it lamb
beef if you're a bee theater
and i'm a bee feeder just so you know dr
wallach has a saying i should have a
t-shirt made like this a day without a
hamburger is like a day without sunshine
he used to say that all the time he was
raised on a beef farm
in missouri as a child so he
he likes to eat beef but
you don't want to eat your if you're
going to eat meat beef steak you want to
eat it either rare or medium rare so
this is where you see the studies say
well rich i saw this study
that eating red meat is carcinogenic
what does that mean cancer causing yes
if it's cooked if it's overcooked
it's the cooking process it's not the
meat it's the heat
that getting those meat that meat to
such high temperatures
okay so beef
red meat it's on dr wallick's good food
list but you want to eat it rare or
medium rare not medium not meet him well
and for sure not well done
that is very very unhealthy thing to eat
your meat
medium well or for sure for well done
right
mixed or salted nuts no peanuts now i
wasn't going to take the time to share
this but years ago
i believe it was uh there was some there
were bears that were dying
in the zoos in the united states
i am wanting to say it was uh the panda
bear i could be wrong about that's been
a while since i told this story but dr
wallach was called in
he used to work with marlon perkins for
those of you
up in years you remember mutual of
omaha's wild kingdom well dr wallach
worked with him
and he was called in to the zoos to
determine why are these bears dying
of cancer they were getting pancreatic
cancer
and
he determined they were feeding them
moldy bread moldy bread
which contained a specific virus that
was causing the cancer in the bears
well dr wallach says
i've not heard anyone else say this but
he says that peanuts
carry that same virus so dr wallach does
not eat peanuts so on our good food list
we have mixed
salted nuts
dr wallick's big on salt if you listen
to the lecture you'll hear him talk
about every farmer puts out salt when
the first thing he puts out for his
livestock
is a salt block but he does not eat
peanuts and that is the reason
beans are on the good food list
any gluten-free carbohydrate except oats
we'll talk about that in a minute
rice
millet pure buckwheat quinoa
corn if it's non-gmo corn that's very
important or on the good food list
vegetables fruits
if you're not diabetic
if you have blood sugar problems
i wouldn't eat any fruits
until you get it under control you know
and again the healthy blood sugar pack
can help you
give you additional
support
in that area of blood sugar
dairy unless you have a dairy allergy
many people do but if you don't dairy's
on the good food list salt there again
i've already mentioned it
nut butters with no extra sugar dr
wolick's not big on a lot of sugar lard
and butter he believes in cooking and
lard
rendered fat
from meat
four to eight ounces
four to eight ounce glasses four to
eight
eight ounce glasses a filter water each
day so he's big on drinking water and
avoiding the soft plastic bottles that
could be harmful
coffee's on the good food list i've
never drank coffee in my life but
my wife drinks it all my kids drink it
all my friends drink it i've just never
drank it tea
green tea and red wine if you're a wine
drinker dr wallick is as big on red wine
the health benefits of red wine now the
bad food list
here we go these first four fall into a
category that's called gluten
gluten is one thing that i
do not touch dr wallock will not it's
not like sugar sugar you're not going to
eliminate 100 of all sugar in your diet
or let me say this it would be very
difficult in this country
but with gluten and same way as dairy if
you have a dairy allergy you can cut
down on the dairy and see some benefit
gluten is not that way
it's all or nothing
so it kind of amuses me when i see
people they'll
you know
because it takes a process took me two
or three weeks to get used to eating
gluten-free now i find anything i like
you can find a gluten-free version pizza
pasta gluten-free cookies anything that
you like chips your you can find a
gluten-free version but there are people
that think they can just cut down on
gluten no you might as well just eat all
the gluten you can get it's all or
nothing
we have another doctor in our company
that says it like this
being gluten free
it's like being
pregnant or not pregnant
every woman
is either pregnant or not pregnant
okay there is no in between
you're pregnant or you're not pregnant
well you're either gluten-free
or you're not gluten-free i think it's a
great
analogy
sugar you can cut down dairy you can cut
down if you need to but with gluten it's
all or nothing gluten-free or not
gluten-free there's no great benefit to
cutting down so here are the four foods
that fall into the category of gluten on
the bad food list wheat barley rye and
oats
even gluten-free oats just because it
says gluten-free oats oats dr wallock
teaches
had the same
the same compound
as the gluten that you find in the wheat
the barley the rice the rye
and here's what the problem with gluten
people will say well
rich i don't have a gluten allergy it's
not an allergy
i don't have a gluten sensitivity it's
not just a sensitivity
gluten
is you so and another argument i hear is
what about the wheat in the bible
well what you're seeing today is a
man-made wheat
it's a hybrid
it's not it's not real they have made
these
products you know the wheat today is
made so that the insects won't eat it
so
people are eating consuming
what the insects won't eat
even the insects are smart enough to
know we're not going to eat this stuff
that's what gluten is and it wreaks
havoc
on your digestive system it's not just
an allergy people say i don't have any
problem with gluten so you think
you may not have a problem today it just
hasn't caught up with you yet
so gluten
it destroys the digestive system
and if there's one step you could take
that is the first thing dr wallach tells
everyone in his lectures step number one
get off of all
gluten and that is sweet barley rye and
oats that would be just that alone
would be a tremendous step to better
health for you even before you start the
supplements
you can still take the supplements but
the gluten will hinder absorption some
people aren't going to get off gluten we
understand that
can't make you do it but it will be a
big benefit and then you're going to get
more out of the money that you're
spending
on the products because you're going to
absorb more so enough about gluten fried
food
fried food it makes me cringe i'm not
going to say i never eat a gluten zero
for me
fried food i'm very conscious you want
to cut down as much as you can because
when you heat those oils
when you cook something in oil those
become carcinogenic very very harmful
all
fried foods which leads to the next oils
even oils in a bottle
and now there are
there are books out there are teachings
about this oil is good for you olive oil
all these things
it doesn't make any difference if it's
pure virgin virgin virgin olive oil
all this coconut oil
when you when oil is exposed to air
and heat so if you're taking oil out of
a bottle every time you open the bottle
it's exposed to oxygen
and it begins to break down
it begins to become rancid through a
process called oxidation and it becomes
harmful for you even if you're not
cooking with for sure when you heat
those temperatures very bad for you so
get rid of all oil and this is the one
that dr wallet gets the most
opposition in his live lectures
people will raise their hand what about
this or finally he gets tired of it and
he just shouts out if it's spelled o i l
get rid of it so that's enough said on
that no oils in a bottle
if you want to follow dr wallach's
guidelines
well done red meat we talked about that
a moment ago if you're going to eat meat
meat's on the good food list but make
sure you eat it rare or medium rare
any nitrates or nitrites where do we
find these you especially find these in
lunch meat
now they do make lunch meats i like
lunch meat myself such an easy thing to
eat and it's quick
and and it's good
it's on the bad food list
only if you're getting the nitrates and
the nitrites you can actually get a deli
meat now
that doesn't have any nitrates or
nitrites and that's what i do it says it
right on the package even some of the
well-known brands
no carbonated drinks of any kind within
one hour
before during or after
you take your supplements
so he doesn't say
no carbonated drinks at all they're not
great for you they're on the bad food
list but for sure if you're going to
drink them anyway
don't drink them they dilute your
stomach acid they hinder the absorption
of these nutrients and then the skin of
baked potatoes it's not the skin that's
bad
it's the baking process so if you boil
your potatoes this is any kind of potato
if you boil your potatoes it's okay
but when you bake those
potatoes now baked potato don't
misunderstand me baked potato is not on
the bad food list it is the skins
of a potato that have been baked and
again it has to do with
the temperature
getting high those skins then become
carcinogenic so if you want to boil your
potatoes and my son tries to argue with
me oh the skins are the best part
they're good for you theoretically he's
right
other than he's
misinformed
on the fact that they become
carcinogenic when you heat them up guys
we're out of time for today
that is nitro wallace good food bad food
list you can print this you can
view it or print it in its entirety by
going to our website mineraldoctor.com
be sure you take the free health
evaluation and then schedule your free
phone consultation and we are looking
forward to hearing from you and hearing
the great things that dr wallach's
message and his products do in your life
very soon